Today,
we're going to talk a little bit more
about the fractionation of openness to
experience.
And
we've done a fair number of studies with
the big five aspect scale,
which we've talked about a lot,
which enables the big five model to be
differentiated down into two aspects per
trait.
And those aspects have been useful for a
variety of reasons.
For example,
when we're looking at political
behavior,
we've been able to determine that
conservatives who are generally regarded
as higher in conscientiousness are
actually more specifically higher in
orderliness,
is not a lot of difference between
liberals and conservatives with regards
to industriousness.
And we've also been able to determine at
least to some degree that orderliness
seems to be associated with disgust,
sensitivity and disgust sensitivity as
part of the behavioral immune system.
And so part of the reasons that
conservatives are more inclined to want
things like closed borders is because
they're more concerned about maintaining
the boundaries between things.
And the reason for that seems to be
fundamentally associated with disgust.
And I'll talk to you a lot about that
next week because once we sorted that
out,
it really,
really illuminated my way of thinking
about things that had happened.
For example,
in Nazi Germany because people tend to,
people tend to think about like when
people have been studying conservatism
from a scientific perspective,
they've tended to assume that it's
associated with fear of the outgroup say
and it conservatives are more fearful to
liberals,
but that actually doesn't seem to be
conservatives are not hiring trait
neuroticism.
And that's a really tough one because if
you are going to make a case that a
group one group is more anxious let's
say,
or threat sensitive than another and you
don't get differences in trait
neuroticism,
then you've really got a problem
over political versus well yeah,
but the theories,
the theories seem to be more trait like
rather than situation.
Yeah.
So,
so,
but what we have found is that that,
you know,
for a long time people thought that all
of the negative emotions loaded on
neuroticism and it was like the global,
it was the global trade for negative
emotion,
but discussed seems to be its own
peculiar thing.
And uh,
but I will talk to you more about that
next week and,
but that's just an example of why
differentiation at the aspect level
seems useful.
You also pick up differences between men
and women at the aspect level that
aren't obvious at the trait level as
well.
So you can think about the model says,
you know,
you have a model that operates at
different levels of resolution and low
resolution representations are good for
one set of operations in higher
other purposes.
And the purpose of course is to predict
these.
That's one of the primary scientific
purposes.
And so you pick the level of analysis
that gives you the most prediction and
perhaps also the most utility in terms
of formulating scientific theories.
So,
and so we'll concentrate a little bit
more today on openness per se.
So openness to experience fragments into
intellect and openness proper.
And I think the right way to think about
intellect is that it's the personality
instantiation of Iq,
roughly speaking.
And the reason I think that is because,
well first of all,
working memory predicts intellect quite
nicely and working memory tests are
very,
very highly correlated with g and s
specifically g being the first factor
that you pull out of any set of Iq
tests,
right?
That that's the technical definition of
GE.
You set up sis,
uh,
sets of questions,
do a factor analysis and extract out the
first factor,
which is roughly equivalent by the way,
to the total or to that to two,
the mean of the,
of the items,
if it's,
if there's a one factor solution,
it's not much different than the
average.
So the average is actually a factor.
That's that,
that where the hypothesis is that every
single item loads equally on that
factor,
right?
Because you're adding them all up and
then dividing them by the number.
So it's no different than a factor
analysis.
Sometimes you'll hear people like
Stephen Jay Gould did this when he was
complaining about Iq back in the 90s he
said of factor a factor analysis.
Like a factor is just a mathematical
abstraction.
It's like,
well yeah,
so is the average.
You think it'd be average of a set of
numbers real and answer that question
is,
it depends on how you define real.
You can use it for certain functions,
which is a pretty good definition of
real as far as I'm concerned.
But when,
when you ask questions like that,
you have to define both your terms and
you do that somewhat arbitrarily
anyways.
People with high iqs tend to think that
they're smart,
which is that's right.
And so then they tend to describe
themselves as smart.
If you give them the opportunity to do
that.
And then that shows up when you ask them
questions about their problem solving
ability and that loads mostly on
intellect.
And so it isn't even obvious that
there's any real utility in assessing
intellect from the self report
perspective when you could replace that
with an Iq test because the Iq test is
way more accurate.
So,
but that gives you some sense.
You think about the whole five factor
model,
you know,
where intelligence slots,
slots in underneath openness,
the openness,
proper part of openness to experience,
which,
which I tend to think about as
creativity.
You can use that at least as a shorthand
to sort of aid your understanding in
what it is.
Creativity seems related to Iq in that
more people with higher iqs are likely
to be creative.
Or if you take people who are noted for
their creativity,
there's a high probability that they'll
have a higher Iq,
but there's more to it than Iq.
Um,
and,
and what,
what creativity seems to be associated
with then again depends on whether or
not how in how you define creativity.
Because you could define it as the sum
total of creative achievements that
you've made in your life,
which would be the actual production of
say,
artifacts of one form or another
performances or inventions or artworks
or,
or what have you.
We'll go over the dimensions in the
middle in a minute.
Or You could also define it as the
proclivity to engage in creative
thought.
And I think we'll start with that first.
So what does it mean to think
creatively?
It's,
it's sort of like,
it's something like this.
Imagine that I tossed you out an idea
and there's some probability that when I
taught you that idea that that will
trigger off other ideas in your
imagination.
So you could think about it as a
threshold issue.
If you're not very creative,
I'll throw you an idea and hardly any
other ideas will be triggered.
And the ones that will be triggered are
going to be very closely associated with
that initial idea.
So let's say I tossed each of you an
idea and I asked you to think,
tell me the first thing that comes to
mind.
Okay.
So what we would see first is that the
first thing that comes to mind for you,
the first thing that comes to mind in
like in all likelihood would be shared
by many of you.
Okay?
So then you could think about that as a
common response,
right?
And so that's a less creative response.
And then there'll be some things that
come to mind for you that are,
that are so idiosyncratic that you're
the only person that thinks that and no
one can understand it.
Well that that's also not exactly
creative because the thing that you,
for something to be creative,
it has to be novel and useful at the
same time.
That's sort of a rough definition,
creative,
something creative is novel and useful.
And obviously,
you know,
there,
there's a,
there's a certain amount of judgment
that goes along with that clearly,
but if it's too novel then no one else
can understand it and it's unlikely to
be useful.
So there's,
there's a,
there's a range of convenience.
So anyways,
if you want to decide if something is
creative,
like what we would do for,
I could say to you,
uh,
okay,
in the next three minutes I want you to
write down all of the uses you can think
of for a brick.
So,
okay.
So someone tells me to use for a brick
breaking windows.
Yes.
Okay.
At what else can use a brick for
build a wall.
It's very small wall,
a wall for ants.
And what else?
Paperweight.
Okay.
Well,
so you get the idea.
Now,
you're not feeling very mouthy today,
obviously,
but so,
so you see that.
So if we gathered your responses,
say I said you have to think of 20 items
that 20 things that that you could do
with a brick,
then a bunch of the things that you
thought would be the same and some
people would come up with something
different.
Like yours was reasonably different.
The one about using it as a pumice stone
for your feet,
that's someone else might've come up
with that.
But it's,
it's a good creative response because
it's unexpected and it,
you could actually do it,
you know?
So anyways,
so you'll get a graph of probability of
response,
right?
And the more probable,
the less creative,
roughly speaking,
it's not the only criteria though,
because you also have to look at
utility.
So if I said,
okay,
you've got three minutes to write down
as many uses as you can think of for a
brick,
I would score that in a variety of ways.
The first thing I would do is just
figure out how many uses you generated.
That's called fluency.
And we could also do that.
I could just say write down as many
words as you can.
Begin with the letter s in three minutes
or that begin with the letter c or four
letter words that begin with the letter
d.
No,
I can,
I can constrain it.
And if I counted how many words you
generated,
if I had an Iq measure and I had a
measure of how many words you generated,
Iq plus the number of words that you
generated would be a better predictor of
your creativity.
Then just Iq.
So there's this fluency element that's,
and so that's something like the rate at
which you can produce,
say verbal ideas.
And one of the things we do know about,
about the creativity dimension of,
of openness is that it is associated
with fluency and it's also associated
with originality.
And originality would be how improbable
your use was compared to the uses
generated by other people.
So,
so anyway,
so you can think of you,
you get thrown in idea and there's some
probability that that will go activate
other ideas and if it coactivators many
other ideas,
that's like fluency and if it coactive
eights ideas that are quite distant from
the original idea,
something like that.
And you could,
you could track distance by comparing it
to two probability that other people
have generated it.
Then that's also another indication of
creativity.
So they have to be unlikely risk.
Many unlikely responses that are useful.
That's what creativity is,
roughly speaking.
And then you can fractionated into
different dimensions.
So that's creative thinking.
But then creative achievement would be
the ability to take those original ideas
and then actually to implement them in
the world.
And that's obviously much more different
than merely being creative.
And so,
and then what creativity is depends on
which of those measurement routes that
you take.
Now I developed a questionnaire with one
of my students,
Shelly Carson about,
gees,
it's just about 30 years ago now,
20 years ago,
I guess,
called the creative achievement
questionnaire.
And I'll show you that here and I'll
show you some of the things that,
that are interesting about it.
Um,
you know,
you hear a very frequently people say
things like everyone's creative.
It's like that's wrong.
Okay,
it's wrong.
It's just as wrong as saying that
everyone's extroverted.
First of all,
you have to be pretty damn smart to be
creative because otherwise you're just
going to get to where other people have
already got.
And that's not creative by definition.
So,
so be in fast and being out there at the
front of things really makes a
difference.
And then you also have to have these
divergent thinking capabilities and
that's part of your traits.
Structure and creative people are really
different than non creative people,
you know,
partly because for example,
they're highly motivated to do creative
things and to experience novelty and to,
and to,
and to chase down aesthetic experiences.
Intuit 10 movies into read fiction and
to go to museums and to enjoy poetry
and,
and to enjoy music.
That's not conventional music,
for example.
These aren't trivial differences.
And so and so.
It's a real,
it's a real miss statement to make the
proposition that everyone's creative.
It's just simply not the case.
It's a matter of wishful thinking.
It's like saying that everyone's
intelligent.
It's like,
well,
if everyone's intelligent,
then the term loses all of its meaning
because any term that you can apply to
every member of a category,
obs has absolutely no meaning.
Now that doesn't end.
You know?
The other thing you want to be thinking
about here is that don't be thinking
that creativity is such a good thing.
It's a high risk,
high return strategy,
so if you're creative,
you just try this.
There's creative people in this room,
man,
you guys are going to have a hell of a
time monetizing your creativity.
It's virtually impossible.
It's really,
really difficult because first of all,
let's say you make an original product,
you think the world will beat a pathway
to your door.
If you build a better mouse trap.
It's like that's complete rubbish.
It isn't.
It isn't true in the least.
If you make a good creative product,
you've probably solved about 5% of your
problem because then you have marketing,
which is insanely difficult.
And then you have sales and then you
have customer support and then you have
to build an organization and you have
to,
if it's really novel,
you have to tell people what the hell
the thing is.
You know,
we built this future authoring program,
right?
And it's available for people online.
It's how do you market that?
No one knows what that is.
And that's a real problem.
If he wrote a book while then you have
the problem that another million people
have also written a book.
But if you produce something that's
completely new and doesn't have a
category,
people can't search for it online,
how are they going to find it?
So you,
you just have,
and then you have pricing problems and
it's really unbelievably difficult to
produce something creative and then
monetize it.
And even worse,
if you're the creative person,
let's say you have a spectacular
invention,
you've got no money,
right?
You've got no customers.
Those are big problems.
And so maybe you go and you find a
venture capitalist.
We start with family and friends because
that's how it works.
He raised money for your product.
You raise money from your family and
friends.
That's assuming you have family and
friends that have some money and that
they're going to give it to you and most
people aren't in that situation.
So it's a terrible barrier right off the
bat.
And then of course you're putting your
family and friends.
It's substantial financial risk because
the probability that you're stupid idea
is going to make money is virtually zero
even if it's a really brilliant idea.
And so then let's say,
well you get past family and friends and
you get venture capitalists,
capitalists involved cause that's often
the next step or an angel investor
that's there's,
there's steps in building a business
family and friends,
Angel investor that some rich guy that
you happened to meet some manner is some
way.
Who's who's into this sort of thing.
Is is willing to provide you with some
money to get your product off the
ground?
Well how much of your product is that
person going to take?
Well,
most of it,
most of it.
And then if you get a venture and no
wonder because you know you don't have
any money,
how are you going to bargain for control
over your product?
He'll just say,
well,
do you want the money or not?
And if your answer is no,
then he'll go and do something else with
his money.
It's not like there's no shortage of
things that you can do with your money.
There's a million things you can do with
it,
so you're not in a great bargaining
position.
And then if you get venture capitalists
involved,
they'll take another big chunk.
And maybe if they're not very straight
with you,
they'll just throw you out.
Because maybe by that point in the
company's development,
you're nothing but a pain in the neck.
Because what do you know about marketing
and sales and customer service and
building an organization and running a
business?
Like you don't have a clue.
So why do they need you?
So even if you're a successful at
generating a new idea and you put it
into a business,
the probability that you as the
originator of the,
of the idea are going to make some money
from it is very,
very low.
So don't be thinking that creativity is
such a,
it's such a,
it's something you would want to curse
yourself with.
Now,
you know,
it's not all bad because it opens up
avenues of experience for creative
people that aren't available to people
who aren't creative.
But it definitely is a high risk,
high return strategy,
you know?
So the overwhelming probability is that
you will fail,
but a small proportion of creative
people succeed spectacularly.
And so it's like a lottery in some
sense.
You're probably gonna lose,
but if you don't lose,
you could win big.
And that keeps a lot of creative people
going.
But also they don't really have much
choice in it because if you're a
creative person,
you're like,
uh,
a fruit tree that's,
that's bearing fruit.
So you don't really have,
you can suppress it,
but it's very bad for you.
You know,
the creative people I've worked with as
if they're not creative,
they're miserable.
So they have to do it.
But,
and,
and you know,
there's real joy and pleasure in it and,
and,
and psychological utility.
But that doesn't necessarily mean that
it's an intelligent,
it's certainly not a conservative
strategy for moving forward through
life.
So,
and you know,
whenever I talk to people who are
creative and you,
you guys should listen to this because I
know what I'm talking about.
If you happen to be creative,
if you're a songwriter or another kind
of musician or an artist or,
or,
or any of the other number of things
that you might be,
find a way to make money and then
practice your craft on the side because
you will starve to death otherwise.
Now some for some of you that won't be
true,
but it's a tiny minority.
You're best bet is to find a job that
will keep body and soul together and
parse off some time that you can pursue
your creative thing.
Because then,
well,
as a longterm strategy of medium to
longterm strategy,
it's a better one.
But it's got incredibly difficult for
people.
Musicians,
for example,
it's incredibly difficult for new
musicians to monetize their,
their craft,
even if they're really,
really good at it.
So it's,
it's,
well,
so anyway,
so don't be,
so I say,
well everyone's not,
everyone's not creative.
And everybody goes,
oh,
that's terrible.
It's like,
it's not so terrible.
It's not something,
it's not self evident that you would
curse someone with high levels of
creativity.
So,
all right,
so here's how our creative achievement
questionnaire works.
What we did essentially was we thought
up how many domains there are in which
you might be creative.
And this is,
remember when you're designing a
questionnaire,
you want to be over inclusive because
the statistics will take care of it,
right?
So you can,
you can take a big area of,
of,
of potential.
You can take a large area and aim your
questionnaire at it and you can do
statistics post hoc to see if you're
covering the area.
If,
if,
if the things that you're measuring or
nicely correlated there,
this,
you know,
there,
there's something about them that's
similar.
If they're not correlated,
then maybe you're measuring two
different things and you can get rid of
one of them.
That's fine.
So we did start with a pretty wide
range.
We thought,
okay,
well what domains can you be creative
in?
Visual Arts,
painting and sculpture.
Then we had experts sort of rank order
levels of achievement within those
domains.
And so if you are a painter you could
zero gives you,
I have no training or recognized talent
in this area.
Okay,
so you really want to keep an eye on the
Zeros.
All right,
so then I've taken lessons.
People have commented on my talents.
I have won a prize.
My work has been critiqued in national
publications.
All right,
so you get,
you get,
you get zero to seven points,
but you can indicate more than,
you know,
maybe that's happened to you more than
once.
So,
and what happens,
this is interesting and is that the
higher you are up in this hierarchy,
the more likely it is that those things
have happened to you more than once.
And that's,
that's another example of this weird
thing called the pareto principle or
price's law.
Which is that it's sort of as good
things happen to you,
that probability that more good things
will happen.
Increases,
right?
So because once you're famous,
people give you all sorts of
opportunities to do other things,
right?
So your,
your,
your success doesn't go like this goes
like this zero zero,
zero skyrocket.
That's how it works.
But getting from zero to getting from
zero to one,
if you're starting a business,
the hardest customer you'll ever get is
your first one.
And then the second hardest one will be
your second one.
It's virtually impossible to get a first
customer because they're going to say to
you,
first of all,
you're going to be selling to people who
are basically conservative and they're
not going to be evaluate.
They're not going to be willing or able
to evaluate whether your damn product is
good for anything.
And so they'll say,
well who are your other customers?
And if your answer to that is,
well we don't have any.
It's like well then why they're going to
be the first one.
No,
because people don't stick their necks
out at all.
Not a bit ever.
And so unless you're well established in
the market,
especially if you're dealing with a big
company,
you can just bloody well forget it.
It's like a three year sales cycle
anyways,
it's re because big corporations move
very,
very slowly.
And you might be able to find a small
company that doesn't have much money,
who would be willing to use your stupid
product for nothing.
If you're really nice to them and you
get one customer that way,
it's very,
very difficult.
And so you'll,
you'll end up,
you know.
And what do you think the royalty,
just out of curiosity,
so I've written a book,
it's going to be published by penguin
random house in,
in January.
What do you think the royalty is for an
author on a book?
So you make something creative,
you get a percentage of the sale.
What do you think the percentages,
just out of curiosity?
Guests?
Yeah,
it's like 5% so think about that.
So that means that you make your thing
and 95% of it belongs to someone else.
And that's if things are going quite
well for you.
And it doesn't really matter what you
manufacture or produce.
That's about what you can expect.
Sales,
marketing,
distribution,
it eats,
he eats it all up so,
so well anyways,
you need to know these things because
they're not self evident.
Okay,
so
seems to be working all by itself.
All right,
so let's take a look.
Well,
how else can you have creative
achievement?
Well,
you can be a musician.
I have no training or recognized talent.
Recordings of my composition have been
sold publicly.
That's the top end.
My composition has been copyrighted,
recorded,
critiqued in local population pop
publication.
I have composed an original piece of
music.
Well,
let's try this.
How many of you have composed an
original piece of music?
Wow,
there's lots of creative people in here
that's very impressive.
So there must be 10 or 11 people in
here.
Oh,
that's cool.
So how about,
uh,
your,
your copies of composition has been
copyrighted.
How about it's been,
the recordings have been sold publicly
and actually sold.
How many people?
Two.
Okay.
Well.
So what you can see is there's a rapid
drop off in the number of people who say
yes.
How many of you fit into categories?
Zero.
I have no training or recognized talent
in this area.
Yeah,
okay.
Okay.
Zero is the median score on all of
these.
Median is the score.
That's the most likely for people to
have,
right?
It's different than the mean.
Median score is zero.
So what's the median score and the
entire creative achievement
questionnaire?
Zero.
You,
you add up all over all 13 domains.
The most typical score is zero.
So that's how creative people are.
There's zero creative,
not at all.
Yes,
certainly that everybody has a certain
degree of creativity,
but for the most part,
most of them are not really creative and
all.
The thing is you could say that people
have people,
all people are creative and that all
people can generate ideas,
but the issue isn't whether or not you
can generate ideas.
It's whether or not you can generate
ideas that are different from the ideas
that other people generate.
That's the critical issue because I
didn't mean it depends on how you define
it.
You can,
while the novelty is a huge part of it,
but that's it.
That sort of built into the definition
of creative.
It has to be novel and useful.
And if your idea that you generate is
the same as the idea that a bunch of
other people have,
it's not,
it's an idea.
Fair enough.
And if you define creativity that way,
then everyone's creative.
But it's a foolish way of defining
creativity because everyone does it.
And we know that there has to be
something novel about creativity.
Um,
these categories all seem to be artistic
as well as requiring specific of skills.
For example,
the music and answer choir,
mechanical motor fields.
Are there ways to be creative outside of
the artistic director?
Well,
let's go through the rest of the domains
because we did include domains that
aren't,
that aren't and yes,
there are,
engineering is a good example of that or
writing nonfiction,
they,
those things tend to tilt more in the
intellect direction.
But I'm concentrating most particularly
here on the sort of creativity that
would be a soap associated with
openness.
So yeah.
Okay.
So dance,
well it's,
it's roughly the same as music,
so we won't,
we won't move forward into that
architectural design.
My architectural design,
my architectural design has been
recognized in a national publication,
creative writing.
My work has been reviewed in national
publications.
Million books sold last year.
250 of them sold more than a hundred
thousand copies.
Right.
So that's another,
that's another example of high risk,
high return.
So probably you won't write a book.
If you write a book,
probably no one would publish it.
If you publish it,
almost certainly no one will buy it.
So you see,
you see what I mean?
There's,
there's exclusion.
The exclusion criteria there are so are
so thoroughly,
they're so difficult because it's very
difficult to write a book,
even a bad one.
You have to work a long time to write a
bad book and then your book has to be
pretty damn good before you're going to
get it published.
And,
and you also have to know about know how
to go about getting it published.
That's all.
So you don't send a book to a publisher,
by the way,
they don't want your stupid book.
They want a summary of the book,
they want an outline of the book,
they want three chapters of the book,
they want to know who the hell you are
and why anyone should listen to you.
They want to know what other books your
book is like.
And most importantly,
perhaps they want to know where it would
sit in a bookshelf in a bookstore.
And the reason for that is that,
and I have trouble this has trouble with
the books that I write is no one who was
where to put them.
That's a big problem because then the
marketing people don't know how to
market them.
And maybe that's because they're more
creative than usual.
It doesn't matter if there isn't a place
that you can put the book where people
can find it,
then you're not going to publish it.
And even if you do,
you can't sell it because no one can
find it.
So you just think about the difficulties
in being a successful author.
You're not going to write a book.
It's too hard.
There's no damn way you're going to get
it published,
and if you do,
it probably won't be a very good
publisher.
Then they have to do a really good job
of selling it and marketing it.
Then you have to enter the,
the the market at the right time,
right?
And then you have to be reviewed by the
right people and then it has to be put
in the right places.
It's like most,
what happens is your book,
we'll go out for a week.
No one will buy it and it'll disappear.
And that's if you've done 99.99% of
things,
right.
So,
okay.
Creative writing or humor.
My humor has been recognized in a
national publication that's the top yet.
And I've written a joke or cartoon that
has been published.
I've written jokes for other people.
I've worked as a professional comedian.
Inventions.
I regularly find novel uses for
household objects.
I've built a prototype of what it,
my designed inventions.
I've sold one of my inventions to people
I know.
Has anyone in here built a prototype of
a design invention?
No one.
Okay.
Um Ha.
Is anyone in here created original
software for a
one,
two,
three people?
Yes.
Three people.
How about um,
I've sketched out an invention and
worked on its design flaws.
How many people?
So maybe two or three.
Yeah.
I mean if this was an engineering class
and in all likelihood there would be
more people in that category,
but that this is more in the domain.
It's not the exactly the artsy end of
the creativity distribution.
It's more on the ideas and,
and mechanical end of it.
And that's a reasonable way of thinking
about it.
I would say.
So.
Um,
scientific discovery,
I do not have training or recognized
stability in this field.
I've received a scholarship based on my
work in science or medicine.
How many people have received a
scholarship based in their work on
science and medicine?
Okay.
Nobody.
So we don't have anybody that goes up
that high.
I have won a prize at a science fair or
other local competition.
Anybody there?
Yes.
There's maybe two or three,
four people there.
So that means we've got four people in a
class of about 150.
Who hit the,
um,
third,
the second level of scientific
discovery.
Anybody received a grant to pursue their
work in science and medicine?
It's hard.
Highly Unlikely.
You guys are mostly too young to have
had that happened to you.
Okay.
So theater and film,
um,
anybody who's at,
how many people have performed in
theater or film?
Oh yeah.
You're an artsy bud shea.
So my acting abilities have been
recognized in local publication.
How many people for that one?
That's it.
Anybody higher than that?
I've directed or produced to theater or
film production one too.
Um,
I've been paid.
There's a good one.
I have been paid to pay one to two.
Okay.
Um,
my theatrical work has,
I've been paid to direct a theater or
film production.
Ha.
Got You there.
So you've done that.
Hey,
congratulations.
You're way the hell up on the list.
Right,
right,
right.
Hard to monetize.
How many films did you make?
You made?
Four.
Did you make any money?
Oh,
you did?
Well,
congratulations.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Well that's a
Canadian filmmakers.
Yeah.
All of a sudden
queerness and then also piracy got
really bad.
Right?
Yeah.
Well that's one of the big problems with
anything that can be distributed
digitally.
It's like,
yeah,
yeah.
Right.
Timing is everything and that's,
it's actually,
well that's,
that's another one of the terrible
cutoffs is that not only do you have to
be right and have yourself together and
produce the proper thing,
but the market has to open its exactly
that moment so that you could walk
through.
There has to be a demand so people won't
buy anything that they don't have a
crying need for it because they have
priority.
Say it's magic.
Everybody has 10 priorities and tet
number 10 is important,
but no one ever does it.
And number eight is important,
but no one ever does.
And so you have to go talk to someone to
buy what you have.
And that has to be priority one or two
for them because they'll say,
oh that's good,
we really need it,
but it's priority eight.
It's like forget it.
They'll never buy your thing cause they
never get to priority eight on their
list of 10 priorities.
They want to get down to like priority
for so.
And then the other thing that'll happen
too is if you go up,
try to sell your product,
you won't know who to talk to it and
you'll end up spending 95% of your time.
This is especially true in companies
with the people who will talk to you,
right?
Obviously.
But those aren't the people who ever
make any decisions.
So they'll tell you all sorts of good
things about your product and how
interested they are.
But they'll never buy because they can't
make it.
They make decisions and you won't be
able to get to the people who make
decisions because other people who know
how to do that have already got there
and that's not you.
So that's very difficult as well.
Culinary Arts,
my recipes have been published
nationally.
Anyone?
How about,
um,
I often experiment with,
and this is purposeful experimentation,
right?
Not accidental experimentation.
Yeah.
Alright.
My recipes have been published in local
cookbook.
Anyone?
No.
Okay.
Well,
you get the,
you get the point,
right?
You see,
you see how this works?
It's just,
well,
here are ways you can be creative and
here are a strata of accomplishment
within those ways.
And so then the question is what does it
look like?
Yes,
yes,
yes.
Fair enough.
And,
and,
and this probably needs to be updated to
reflect that.
So,
so there's,
there's the distribution of scores.
Now that's dismal.
That's a dismal thing to look out.
You have to understand that,
why look at this zero,
right?
The median person has not done anything
creative ever in their life with
anything on any dementia,
right?
It's really important to know that.
And then you have these horrible people
out here,
right?
They do everything.
Price's law.
Here's price's law.
This is something to hammer into your
heart.
The square root of the number of people
in a domain do 50% of the work.
Okay?
So let's,
let's go through that.
You have 10 employees,
three of them do.
Half the work makes sense.
That's reasonable.
You have a hundred employees,
10 of them do half the work.
That's problem.
So the other 90% are doing the other
half.
Who cares about them?
You have 10,000 employees,
a hundred of them do half the work,
right?
So here's a,
here's a nasty little law.
As your company grows in,
competence grows into exponentially and
competence grows linearly.
Got It.
Right?
Because it with 10 it's three who are
doing half the work,
but at 10,000 it's a hundred that are
doing half the work.
So 9,900 of your employees are doing as
much as the best 100 you might not even
know who the best 100 are,
but probably they know and maybe their
peers know too.
And so one of the things that's really
interesting when big companies start to
shake,
which means maybe they've had a bad
quarter,
two bad quarters and the stock price
starts to tip down.
And the people,
the heart,
people who have options are not very
happy about that.
And maybe they start to announce
layoffs.
The hundred people who have
opportunities leave and they're the ones
who were doing half the work.
So boy that puts your company in a
pretty rough situation because now
you've got the 19 900 people left over
who were only doing half the work and
the next time you announce layoffs,
the next most productive hundred leave.
And so then you're left with nobody
who's productive at a massive overhead
payroll price's law.
You can look that up.
Desal,
a price to solar price is a guy who was
looking at scientific productivity and
one of the things he found was when he
was looking at Phd students is that the
median number of publications for a phd
graduate when he did his work,
which was in the early sixties was one,
okay,
half as many had two half as many as
that had three half as many as that had
four.
It's a real step down and one of the
corollaries of that is that there's a
certain number of people who are hyper
productive and that's these people out
here.
And if you were graphing the
distribution,
let's say you graft,
how many people in that population of
300 had $10,000 in a savings account?
It would look very much like this.
Some of them would have are some of
them.
Some of them would.
Most people would have like no savings
whatsoever.
The median person would have no savings
And then you go up here where the 1% is,
they have all the money.
But the thing you want to understand
about that 1% issue that you always hear
about is that it applies in every single
realm where there's difference in
creative production.
Every realm,
it doesn't matter.
Number of records produced,
number of records sold,
number of compositions written.
So here,
here's a,
here's an example,
five composers produce the music that
occupies 50% of the classical rep
repertoire,
right?
Bach,
Beethoven,
Brahms,
Tchaikovsky,
Mozart.
That's right.
Those five.
Okay,
so here's something cool.
So you take all the music,
those people wrote 5% of the music.
All those people wrote occupies 50% of
the music that of their writing that's
played.
So not only do,
almost all the composers never get
Alyson,
but even among the composers who do get
less,
almost none of their music ever gets
played.
So,
so then that's a,
that's another example of this price's
law scaling.
So when it applies to all sorts of
things,
like number of hockey goal scored is
also distributed this way.
Number of basketball basketball backs
basketballs successfully put through the
hoop,
follows the same distribution.
Uh,
size of cities follows the same
distribution.
It's a weird,
it's a weird law.
And you,
you can think about it in part a,
why does this happen?
While imagine what happens when you play
monopoly.
What happens?
Everybody has the same amount of money
to begin with,
right?
So then you start playing,
it's basically a random game while some
people start to win a bit and some
people start to lose a bit.
And then if you win,
the high probability that you'll keep
winning starts to increase.
And if you lose your vulnerability
increases as you lose.
And then maybe you've got say six people
playing monopoly,
soon.
One person has zero.
What happens when they have zero?
They're out of the game.
So zero's a weird number because when
you hit zero,
you're out of the game.
So,
so then if you keep playing,
people start to stack up at zero,
right?
What happens at the end of the game?
One person has all the property and all
the money and everyone else has none,
right?
That's what happens if you play an
iterated trading game to its final
conclusion,
and that's part of the law in a sense
that's underlying this kind of
distribution.
So it's a,
it's a really,
it's,
it's not a consequence necessarily of
structural inequality.
It's built into the system at a deeper
level than that.
So we get know people talk about all the
time about how unfair it is that the 1%
of the population has the vast amount of
the money and 1% of the 1% has most of
that money.
And 1% of the 1% of the 1% has most of
But it is a,
it's a,
it's an inevitable conclusion of
iterated trading games and we don't know
how to fight it.
We don't know how to take from the
people who have and move it to the
bottom without an instantly moving back
up to the top.
Different people maybe,
but still back up to the top.
Cause even the 1% churns a lot.
Like I think you have a 10% chance,
if I remember correctly,
you have a 10% chance of being in the
top 1% for at least one year of your
life and a 40% chance of being in the
top 10% for at least one year in your
life.
That's in Canada and the US,
it's less so in Europe,
so there's a fair bit of churning at the
top end.
It's not the same people all the time
who have the money,
but it is a tiny fraction of the people
all the time who have all the money.
Yeah.
Some people
do.
The people inside redistribute to
recreate the scene?
No,
unusually.
I mean they do,
but it's attenuated because the people,
I mean
few reshuffled the entire company and
put everywhere somewhere else.
There's some probability that some of
those people would rise to the top that
weren't at the top before,
but in that company,
that isn't generally what happens.
People get stuck in their niche and they
don't move.
So yeah,
this is cool.
You wonder sometimes,
well,
how can companies die so quickly?
Well,
they go,
they go into a death spiral that's
almost impossible for them to get out
of.
So,
and it happened.
It can happen extraordinarily quickly.
This is why,
you know,
the typical fortune 500 company only
lasts 30 years.
That's it.
It's not that easy for these Bay Ammas
to continue existence across time.
So,
and it's because it's really easy for
something to die.
It's very unlikely that it will be
built.
successful and one successful.
It's very unlikely that it will continue
to duplicate it success because the
underlying landscape shifts on it and it
doesn't know where to go.
And that's also partly because it's not
that easy to integrate creative people
into your company.
Right?
You certainly don't want them at the
bottom because they're supposed to be
people who are doing what they're told
to do.
So you filter out a lot of them at the
bottom and then you need them at the
top.
But they've already been filtered out.
And also creative people are troublesome
to work with because they're always,
how do you evaluate a creative person?
You won't,
you almost can't by definition,
because they keep coming up with new
things and you don't have a good
evaluative strategy for a new thing.
It wouldn't be new if you had a good
evaluative strategy for it,
right?
It would have to be the member of a
class that you've already encountered
substantially.
So anyway,
so the take home lesson from this is
zero,
right?
Right.
And then that's like,
that's like a graph of of money,
monetary distribution as well.
And the thing,
the problem with being at zero is very
difficult to get out of zero.
This is also why people get stuck in
poverty.
You know,
you can't get a bank account if you're,
if you don't have any money,
right?
There's a bunch of things that start to
move against you when you're at zero
that you can't shake.
It's very difficult to get out of the,
to get out of the pit here because zero
is a kind of pit.
Okay.
So now we've got the creative
achievement questionnaire and we're
going to take your score and your score
has a summed across all the categories
and all the exemplars of the categories
that you've chosen.
So then the question is,
well,
can you predict creative achievement?
And and this is,
this is,
this is how we did it.
This was construct validation.
The first thing we wanted to know was,
well it was the creative achievement
questionnaire actually associated with
something that you might regard his
creativity.
Okay.
So we,
we got uh,
a number of,
of,
of students to come in and we gave them
a collage kit.
And so then everybody got exactly the
same Kipp and then we had to make a
collage out of the collage kit.
And then we have five artists rate the
collage for quality.
And then we averaged across the ratings.
Now,
the first thing you would do if you did
that is cause he would might think,
well,
can artists actually come up with an a
measure of how creative a collages and
the answer to that is actually
technical.
If all say you guys are the panel,
if all of you identified the same
collages as of high quality and the same
ones as of low quality,
then we can assume that there's
something about your judgment that's
like independent of your idiosyncrasies.
We could say,
well there is a judgment that emerges as
a consensus across artists.
And the first thing we found was that
there was,
there was quite a high correlation
between each artists judgement of the
quality of the collages.
I can't remember what the interrater
reliability was,
but it was something like 0.8 it was
really high.
So it was clear that trained artists
could make reliable judgments about the
quality of collages because you had to
check that out first because if they're
all over the place,
you've got no measure.
Right?
It's like everyone's using a different
rulers got no measure,
so they have to be using the same
router.
While we found that the correlation
between the creative evaluation of
collages and the total caq was 0.59
which is mind boggling.
I told you last time that under 5% of
published social studies,
social science studies have,
are,
are uh,
demonstrate at a correlation coefficient
of an effect size greater than 0.5.
This is 0.6 and if you,
if you square it,
0.5 squared is 25% of the variance 0.6
squared is 36% of the variance 0.6 is a
lot more than 0.5 and 0.5 is unheard of.
And so the fact that you could estimate
someone's lifetime creative achievement
by having them do a collage that for
artists,
uh,
rate was an indication that there really
is something real at the bottom of it,
right?
Because that's like the definition of
real,
the creative personality scale.
You,
you circle adjectives that are
associated with creativity from a very
large list of adjectives that work
pretty well.
Goldberg's adjective markers.
That's another big five variant that was
correlated at about 0.5.
One it doesn't measure openness to
experience,
it just measures intellect.
Um,
but be that as it mate,
it's still an personality marker of,
of,
of trade openness.
It was correlated at 0.5.
One the neo pir openness was correlated
at 0.3,
three and then we use the divergent
thinking tests and I told you about
those already's.
How many uses can you think of for a
brick for example.
And so those are scored according to
fluency,
how many answers you provide.
And then also originality,
how many unique useful answers do you
provide.
And that was nicely correlated as well.
Overall correlation of 0.47 and then
fluency 0.38,
originality 0.4,
six and flexibility 0.37.
So,
so what does that mean?
Well,
the creative achievement questionnaire
indexes lifetime creative achievement in
a way that's powerfully associated with
actual creative production of a single
item plus creative create creativity as
it's indexed by personality markers.
Um,
the Caq is also potently predicted by
Iq,
which is exactly what you'd expect.
So you can do at an extraordinarily good
job of determining how likely someone is
to have high levels of creative
achievement across their life span by
using psychometric tests.
So it means that creativity is a real
thing.
That's the first thing,
both in terms of thinking creatively and
that would be the divergent thinking
tests and also in terms of creative
production and the and that creative
production and creative thinking are
quite tightly aligned.
So,
so that was good.
That's been a very influential paper.
I think it's got about 500 citations.
Now.
People use the creative achievement
questionnaire a lot to assess
creativity.
It's also associated with a higher than
average likelihood of psychosis.
And the other thing you see with
creative people is that they tend to,
especially if they're writers,
they tend the pathology that goes along
with that is often manic depressive
disorder.
And that's partly because manic people
become unbelievably fluid,
right?
They can,
they speak incredibly quickly.
They generate ideas like mad and it's a
hyper arousal of the positive emotions
system,
roughly speaking.
And that can have as a side effect
creativity.
So
this is a cool study.
I just found this one today.
It's a terror management study,
so what?
Well,
I'll read it to you.
The relationship between creativity and
symbolic immortality had been long
acknowledged by scholars.
In your review of the literature,
we found 12 papers that empirically
examined the relationship between
creativity and mortality awareness using
it terror management theory paradigm
overall supporting the notion that
creativity plays an important role in
the management of existential concerns.
Also,
a mini metro analysis of the impact of
death awareness on creativity resulted
in a small,
medium weighted mean effect.
We examine the existential buffering
functions of creative achievement as
assessed by the creative achievement
questionnaire in a sample of 108
students at a high but not low levels of
creative goals.
Creative achievement was associated with
lower death thought accessibility under
mortality salients.
Well,
that means if you remind people that
they're going to die,
the creative people were less likely to
generate death related thoughts as a
consequence to our knowledge,
this is the first empirical report of
the anxiety buffering functions of a
creative achievement among people for
whom creativity constitutes a central
part of their cultural worldview.
It's like a empirical examination of
some of the existential theories that I
was presenting to previously.
Because part of the idea that was put
forth to say by people like nature was
that one of the ways to fight back
against existential anxiety and death
anxiety and all of that is to engage in
creative production.
And so that was actually put the
empirical test in this study.
So I thought that was quite cool.
So here's another paper.
This was by Kauffman and a couple of my
students,
Jacob Hersch and Colin Young,
I'm on that paper as well,
near the end there.
Um,
they were interested in whether openness
and intellect predicted different
elements of creative achievement.
Sort of goes back to your question about
the differentiation between the artsy
and of creativity and maybe the more
practical it and,
and,
uh,
the practical land associated,
for example,
with a proclivity,
but like nonfiction,
the big five personality,
dimension,
openness slash,
intellect
is the trait most closely associated
with creativity and creative
achievement.
Little is known.
However,
regarding the discriminant validity of
it's two aspects.
Discriminant validity is whether one
aspect predicts one set of things and
the other aspect predicts a different
set of things.
If there's no discriminant validity,
if they can't be used for different
purposes,
then there's no point having them.
So you want to see that they're actually
capable of differentiating between
between real world phenomena,
two of its aspects,
openness to experience.
Okay.
Reflecting cognitive engagement with
perception,
fantasy aesthetics and emotions and
intellect,
reflecting cognitive engagement with
abstract and semantic information
primarily through reasoning in relation
to creativity.
In four demographically diverse totaling
over a thousand participants,
we investigated the independent
predictive validity of openness and
intellect by assessing the relations
among cognitive ability,
divergent thinking,
personality and creative achievement
across the arts and sciences.
We confirmed that hypothesis that
openness predicts creative achievement
in the arts
and intellect predicts creative
achievement in the sciences,
inclusion of performance,
measures of general cognitive ability.
That's Iq and divergent thinking
indicated that the relationship of
intellect to scientific creativity may
be due,
at least in part to these abilities.
Lastly,
we found that extroversion additionally
predicted creative achievement in the
arts independently of openness.
So what that means is that creative
achievement in the arts is actually a
function of the higher order trait
plasticity,
right?
Cause plasticity was openness plus
extroversion,
and that's associated fundamentally with
activation of the underlying
dopaminergic system,
which is the system that mediates
exploratory behavior.
So if you're dominated by that,
the function of that system,
you're an exploratory,
gregarious person,
then you're more likely to manifest
creative ability in the arts.
So
apparently
it's time to stop.
I think that's the same student who
always does that,
isn't it?
All right,
we'll see you on Tuesday.